Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar and you're watching Mind Your Decisions
Here's a fun problem given to elementary school students in China:
How tall is the table based on the following pictures?
I adapted this problem from a tweet by China Focus.
Can you figure it out?
Give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching the video for a solution.
[3]
[2]
[1]
So one way to solve this problem is to use algebra.
The first picture, we can translate into the following equation:
We have the height of the cat plus the height of the table minus the height of the turtle is equal to 170.
The second picture will correspond to the equation:
The height of the turtle plus the height of the table minus the height of the cat is equal to 130.
So now from these two equations, we need to solve for the height of the table.
There's a neat little trick we can do - we can add these two equations together.
The variables of cat and turtle will then cancel out.
So we have two times table is equal to 170 plus 130 which is 300
and therefore table is equal to 150
so the height of the table is a hundred and fifty centimeters.
That's one way we can solve the problem.
Now there's also a clever way if you think visually:
Imagine stacking these two pictures on top of each other.
Now notice the height from the top of the cat at the bottom
to the top of the cat at the top is equal to
130 plus 170 which is 300.
We can then erase the animals from the picture
And then we can rearrange it and we can clearly see
that the height of two tables is 300
So the height of one table will be 150 centimeters.
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video
These map videos which can be watched for free on YouTube
inspire and build confidence for people around the world
and they already have over a hundred million views.
Let's share the beauty of mathematics.
With your help we can "math" the world a better place.
Please subscribe for free to get the newest videos.
Watch and share all of Mind Your Decisions videos.
E-mail me a puzzle or math topic. (presh [at] midyourdecisions [dot] com
If you so choose, you can check out my books, which are listed in the video description
and you can support me on Patreon for exclusive rewards.
Thanks for watching and thanks for your support